[Music]
so the title of my talk is nature's
rhymes it's been said that history
doesn't repeat itself but it does rhyme
the curious thing about the quote is
that although somebody definitely said
it it doesn't seem to be clear who did
it's most often attributed to the writer
Mark Twain however you can easily find
websites claiming that there's no
evidence that Mark Twain ever said it
and I wasn't able to find any websites
that said in that case who did make this
remark but it's an often cited remark
and at any rate regardless of what's the
case about history physics definitely
often does repeat itself with similar
structures found in many different
realms of physics often involving many
different scales of length and energy
and many different types of physics so
at the beginning of my talk I'll give
one example that involves waves we've
all seen ripples of water waves on the
surface of a pond or swimming pool as in
this picture so that's a very familiar
example of a wave the distance between
successive ripples is large enough that
we easily see them but in the case of
light visible light like from those
lamps behind us
the distance behind successive ripples
is much too small for us to perceive
unless we're very clever about how we go
about it but in everyday life even if we
see wave phenomena as in some details of
rainbow we don't usually recognize what
we're seeing it wasn't clearly
understood that light is a wave until
experiments that were performed by
Thomas Young in the early 19th century
so he was a giant figure in his day he
was the one who firmly established the
light was a wave he made the first
measurements of the sizes of molecules
that's generally accepted today as being
correct and he also was a pioneer in
deciphering the Egyptian hieroglyphs you
didn't quite get all the way but he got
at least 60 or 70 percent of the way
toward deciphering the hieroglyphs and I
mentioned that because he lived in an
age when it was possible to be expert on
a lot of things nowadays it's usually a
challenge enough to try to be expert on
one thing anyway in his double slit
experiment he basically gave light the
chance to pass through two different
paths
to arrive at some place where it's
observed and he saw effect similarly
similar to the way that the waves on the
surface of the pool add and subtract at
different places so that's when it was
clearly established that light is a wave
well so they're waves in everyday life
light is a wave but in the 20th century
a new kind of wave was discovered that
you could call a matter wave so it was
found that also an electron or a heavier
particle like an atomic nucleus can
behave as a wave but it's hard to give a
real picture showing the electron is a
wave so instead this is a kind of
computer simulation of what an electron
wave inside an atom looks like and the
bright and dark spots are a little bit
analogous to the ripples on the surface
of a swimming pool where the waves add
or cancel so if you study physics as an
undergraduate you'll learn about all
kinds of waves you'll learn about the
equations for water waves you'll learn
about the waves that propagate up and
down a vibrating string you'll learn
about light waves and you'll learn about
electron waves and other matter waves so
there are important differences between
all these wave equations but they have a
lot in common so that's an example of
what I mean when I say that nature
rhymes so if you do study physics even
at the undergraduate level you learned
about wave equations and then you'll be
come to appreciate what I've said that
the four examples I've given of waves
the waves on a pond or a swimming pool
the waves on a string a violin string
light waves and matter waves all have a
lot in common although they have
important differences so there are
completely different realms of physics
but there's some ingredients in common
in the way we describe them so that's
what I mean when I say that nature
sometimes rhymes but there's a different
rhyme that I want to talk about today
and this rhyme actually has two parts so
one part is well established and one
part is speculative
the well-established part of the rhyme
is an analogy between well-established
20th century quantum mechanical laws
that describe the behavior of an
elementary particle like an electron and
what's perhaps the most inaccessible
mystery in physics this mystery is apply
is how to apply quantum mechanics what's
arguably the deepest theory we have
Einstein's theory of gravity which he
called general relativity the
speculative side is an extension of this
rhyme in which particles are replaced by
strings possibly unraveling some of the
big questions now to oversimplify
somewhat and it's awkward to make such
an oversimplification because Steve
Weinberg who's just published a very
nice book in the history of science is
in the front row something I didn't
anticipate well now to limb with his
oversimplification but anyway to
oversimplify the ancient Greeks thought
that the natural state of an object was
to be at rest and motion had to be
explained this view seemed to be based
on common sense bodies in motion
eventually come to rest and lost someone
stops pushing or at least that's our
experience here on earth it's a true
observation but from a modern point of
view it's not simple to explain what's
happening if you kick a ball on the
floor and it eventually comes to rest
what is really happening there that's
not that simple to explain the modern
view is that the energy of the moving
body that's slowing down due to friction
is converted into heat and heat really
consists of microscopic motion of all
the little particles that make up the
body and whatever it's in contact with
so that's a modern point of view but it
wasn't available when science was
getting started in the modern sense in
the 17th century that what I've just
summarized here is really a view that
emerged in the second half of the
nineteenth century
so although the observation of that
bodies in motion eventually come to rest
if you don't keep pushing is true it's
not a very good starting point
site four basing your understanding of
the world because it's just too
difficult to explain what's going on
there Galileo and then especially Newton
made progress in the 17th century not by
understanding all that it was still two
centuries in the future to really
understand what happens when the moving
body slows down but by identifying
simpler questions that could be
described by simpler theories so Newton
focused on questions like the motion of
an isolated body like a planet or for
that matter a ball moving in the air
before it strikes the ground after it
strikes the ground we have to worry
about what really happens when it meets
the ground and then as I said it was two
centuries in the future to understand
even roughly what was happening but as
long as the ball is just moving in the
air that's something that was in the
realm of what Newton could describe
since ancient days it had been argued
that the earth must be at rest or we
would feel its motion but Galileo
refuted this by arguing that a passenger
in a smoothly moving ship in a calm sea
does not feel the motion and that was
the first inkling that to be in a state
of constant velocity is as natural as to
be at rest so Newton redefined the
problem from explaining velocity to
explaining a change in velocity the
natural state of things is that a
particle in motion let's say an empty
space not under the influence remains in
motion with a constant velocity so
according to Newton what has to be
explained is the acceleration or the
change in velocity the most elementary
way to state Newton's idea is by an
equation you've probably all learned in
high school F equals MA that says that
the acceleration or change in velocity
is basically determined by the force
that's acting on the particle so you can
relax that's almost the only equation
we'll have
so a is the acceleration M is the mass
and F is the force causing the
acceleration but then writing it down
the main point I wanted to say is that
what is explains as the acceleration or
change in velocity not the velocity
itself so Newton's law of motion gave a
framework to determine what will happen
for all times if you know what is what
is there at a given time so if you know
where a particle is and how it's moving
at some initial time that might be for
example today at noon the Newton would
offer to tell you where it will be in
the future at any given time so the in
this picture the red ball is meant to
indicate the Sun the small red dot is a
planet and the arrow is supposed to tell
you the direction in which the planet is
moving at the initial time for example
noon today and the length of the arrow
tells you how fast it's moving so
Newton's initial conditions are given by
the position and the velocity arrow and
then the problem that Newton defines is
to predict the orbit of the planet so
it'll start out moving along this arrow
because that's its initial direction of
motion
however it's attracted to the Sun so its
orbit will be bent and calculating that
orbit is what Newton did so this is what
people mean when they say that classical
Newtonian physics is deterministic the
whole idea is to be able to predict the
future given what there is at some
initial time now what I've just
described is an idealized problem and in
a sense that was the main idea
so as I've already told you I didn't
realize Steve would be here but anyway
in the words of the Nobel laureate Steve
Weinberg a but above and beyond any
specific details the real revolution
that got modern science going was in his
words the shift that took many centuries
from trying to give qualitative
descriptions of everything to carefully
selected phenomena where you could give
ponta dative explanations so Newton
didn't try to explain in detail what
happens when a body slows down because
of friction well okay in some idealized
situations yes but it turns out a much
better place to get started
is the motion of the planets around the
Sun and then there was a precise
mathematical theory if you pick the
right questions now one thing that
physicists learned about as a
consequence of Newton's laws was the
concept of energy so our idealized
particle moving in the gravitational
field for example the Sun has an energy
that I'll call E and it's a combination
of two things so one part of the energy
tells how fast the particles moving
that's often called T the kinetic energy
and then there's another term V that
tell us how far the particle is from the
Sun so the energy okay this is almost
our last equation the total energy is
the sum of an energy due to motion and
an energy that has to do with where you
are in the field of the Sun so the great
thing about it is that as the particle
moves its total energy doesn't change T
and V change but the total energy does
not change so this is a schematic
picture of a planet going in an
elliptical orbit around the Sun when
it's close to the Sun is moving fast so
it's kinetic energy is bigger but since
it is close to the Sun its potential
energy is less how does it move farther
from the Sun it slows down its kinetic
energy is less but its potential energy
is bigger so anyway the great thing
about the energy is that it's a constant
and that helps you understand the motion
of the planet now for a long time after
Newton the framework of physics was
consisted largely of refining and
polishing what Newton had done but in
that period people came to understand
Newtonian physics far better than Newton
net and some of the things that were
discovered were very important
afterwards and I'll just tell you about
one which is that 18th century
physicists discovered a remarkable thing
called the principle of least action so
in the terminology that physicists
usually used in practice oil boiler and
Lagrangian T good so I usually get most
of the credit along with the more
but apparently the first glimmering was
by Gottfried Leibniz in 1707 so that's
another difference from the 18th century
to today liveness didn't publish his
idea but described it in the letter and
actually the ladder was lost so we only
know about it because of letters other
people wrote describing Leibniz his
letter so you couldn't get any credit
for a scientific idea nowadays but
apparently in the 18th century you could
now these individuals were amazingly
diverse in their contributions and as I
said before talking about young this was
an age where it was possible for one
person to know what there was to know
about many different fields maybe not
everything but many many fields so they
all had very diverse contributions for
example Leibniz is probably most known
as a great mathematician the co-inventor
of calculus and as a philosopher and
theologian Euler was one of the great
mathematicians of the century or really
of all times and that's what he he's
most famous for but in the 18th century
anyone who was a well educated
mathematician would have been familiar
with the physics of the day that's not
true today understanding the physical
theories we have today is much more of a
challenge and most mathematicians of
today no matter how well educated and
successful in their fields would not
have the kind of knowledge of physics
that not just Euler but any of his
mathematical contemporaries would have
had in the 18th century about the
physics of that day now ok I took this
list from Wikipedia and it sounds crazy
but wikipedia says that the more
important was distinguished in all those
fields that I've listed and I listed
them indiscriminately you'll notice that
some of those fields made more progress
in later centuries than others and I
guess in the 18th century people didn't
have our present view of what fields
were more promising but anyway he was
one of the pioneers of the principle of
least action and l'orange
actually was the one who put it in the
form that students
today so if as an undergraduate you
learned the principle of least action
you'll probably learn Lagrange's version
anyway these people instead of adding
the potential energy to the kinetic
energy to make the total energy e did
the opposite they subtracted V from T
and then since the difference t minus V
is not independent of time they average
over time or to be more precisely
integrated over time to make the action
t minus V that's essentially our last
equation so they took the definition of
the energy and change the sign or at
least this is Lagrange's formulation
which followed a couple generations of
earlier versions well what good is it to
take the wrong sign so that you have
something that is not independent of the
time well they were able to reformulate
Newton's laws in a way that sounds kind
of crazy in this formulation you assume
you know where an object was at some
early time say noon on Tuesday and you
know where it will be later on say at
noon the following Sunday and the
question is to figure out how the
particle will get from A to B so we're
given that at noon on Tuesday it was
here and at noon on Sunday it will be
here and then given that information how
did you get from A to B well the answer
is that among all possible paths from A
to B the particle follows the path of
least action in other words the path
that roughly speaking makes the action I
as small as possible is the quantity
that was - it's not the energy because
there was a sign mistake it's the wrong
quantity that isn't independent of time
but the path if it's true that the
particle was here at noon Tuesday and
will be here at noon Sunday then
traveled between them on the path that
made the action as small as possible so
this sounds crazy because it contradicts
determinism you're supposed to start
with the knowledge of where the particle
will be later on and then check out all
possible paths
so it's not like Newton and it says you
know where you are and how you're moving
at noon on Tuesday and then I'll tell
you where you'll be later on here you
need to have knowledge about Tuesday and
also knowledge about Sunday and then the
goal is to figure out where you were at
a given moment on Thursday so in spirit
it doesn't sound deterministic but
LaGrant and his predecessors showed that
this is actually a perfectly good
Restatement
of newton's laws but it sounded it
sounds quite different from Newton's
approach in which at any moment you try
to say what will happen next
it involves taking a global look at the
whole history and in the 18th century a
lot of philosophical significance was
attached to the principle of least
action demócrata for instance described
it by saying that nature is thrifty in
all its actions and claimed that the
principle of least action proves the
existence of God well ok that was the
principle of least action in the 18th
century well zoom forward to the 20th
century when quantum mechanics was
invented so it's full of surprises and
it shocked people because it was not
causal or deterministic in a traditional
sense so it shocked people in all kinds
of ways which could have easily made the
whole lecture so for example a particle
like the electron behaves as a wave I
showed you a computer picture of
electron wave near the beginning of the
talk but for what I'm saying now it
shocked people because it wasn't causal
in any traditional sense even with the
complete knowledge of what there is
right now or knowledge that's as
completed as quantum theory allows you
can't predict with certainty what will
happen in the future according to
quantum mechanics nevertheless the
theory was extraordinarily successful at
describing atoms and molecules and then
when the subatomic particles were
discovered it was extremely successful
at describing those and it's much too
big a story to try to explain now but
among many other things quantum
mechanics was interpreted by the great
20th century physicist Paul Dirac and
Richard Feynman
in a way that shed light on the
principle of least action so this makes
some sense because quantum mechanics
isn't deterministic in any conventional
sense and the principle of least action
makes it sound like Newton's laws aren't
deterministic even though they are so it
makes sense that the two would go
together actually this is what I just
said
since quantum mechanics is not
deterministic and the principle of least
action sounds unnatural in the
deterministic theory it's kind of
logical for them to go together
what Dirac and Fineman came up with is
this the quantum particle really does
sample all paths from A to B not just
the classical paths but all of them so
I've drawn the classical path which
means the path that abase Newton's laws
what Newton would tell you is the
correct path but now I've drawn another
path and the blue wiggly line is nothing
in particular it's just a path that the
particle could have said a followed that
doesn't debate Newton's laws but
according to draw confinement the
quantum particle samples all paths from
A to B including crazy-looking paths so
here's a crazy-looking path but that's
also a possible path for a quantum
particle so every path contributes but
with a wildly oscillatory factor and
this will I think this really is my last
well mathematical formula so the sum
will recognize what it is but anyway if
you don't
every path contributes but the way they
contribute involve wild wild
oscillations so that the paths that are
too far from the classical path ends up
not being that importance the result of
sampling all paths in the way that Dirac
and Fineman said is that paths that are
too far from the classical path come
very close to canceling out the dominant
quantum mechanical contribution comes
from the path with least action in the
18th century terminology so the way the
paths cancel out is a lot like
interference of waves with which we
began so if you look at the ripple
on top of a swimming pool they're coming
from all different directions probably
because somebody's splash into the pool
and they're reflected from the boundary
and so on and there will be places where
the waves add up and places where they
cancel so the the heights the peaks of
the waves are a little bit analogous to
what happens when the quantum
contribution comes primarily from a path
that has the least action which means
from a path that's close to the
classical path but Fineman extended the
picture beyond what I've explained and
this what I'm about to tell you was
actually Richard Feynman's most
celebrated contribution to physics
he described interactions of elementary
particles in terms of what he called
elementary processes visualized in
space-time at which particle splits in
two or two particles combined so I've
drawn a space-time picture space runs
horizontally time runs vertically a
particle a comes in in the past and we
assume it was initially at rest at some
given time it splits into two particles
let go out in opposite directions for
example it might have been in neutral pi
meson that after all decays the two
photons but anyway in this example of
particle splitting into two and if we
drew the same picture upside down or if
I simply reversed the arrow and said the
time was running down we'd have two
particles coming in and joining into one
so those were the examples of fineman's
elementary processes now not only does a
single particle according to Fineman
sample all possible paths but one
particles are interacting with each
other they sample all possible histories
so here is roughly speaking a classical
history for scattering with two
particles so again time runs this way in
space runs horizontally in this example
two particles have come in from the past
and they scatter to up possibly
different particles go out in the future
and in between there were a variety of
fineman's elementary processes where two
particles combined into one or one split
into two depending on how you look at
the picture so
what I've drawn roughly is a classical
history for scattering of two particles
but Fineman would say that the actual
quantum mechanical scattering involves
considering quantum histories and
quantum history is anything so I've so
I've drawn just a wiggly history so
still two came in and two came out after
the same elementary processes but I've
connected them with wiggly lines because
a quantum particle samples all possible
paths so just to repeat this is the
classical history for particle
scattering and here's an example of a
quantum history but the quantum history
could be anything at all I could have
drawn something much crazier but if you
try to draw something as crazy as a
truly generic quantum history you
actually wouldn't be able to see it it
would just look fuzzy and that's because
so that you can see this there's a width
of all these lines and that width would
the important if I try to show the
particle zigzagging back and forth like
a quantum particle might you'd end up
with only a blur and that's in a sense
that's the right answer because after
all there is an electron wave the blur
would symbolize the fact that in quantum
mechanics particles behave as waves now
the classical history obey some
deterministic equation the particles
travel in straight lines except when
they join or split and there are rules
for the angles when that happens so here
okay this is schematic that I drew
straight lines well with simple angles
but the angles depend on the masses of
the particles and stuff like that but
anyway this is the deterministic picture
and this isn't this is the quantum
history is anything so the quantum
history can be anything at all the only
thing that brings some order to a
quantum universe is that very wild
quantum histories are unlikely because
of the way the waves interfere and
that's why we don't I mean we don't see
quantum mechanics in everyday life
because at the macroscopic scale at
which we live
the wave interference has killed out the
things that are too far from the
classical picture so the classical
picture works pretty well at a human
length scale so it's again a little bit
like the ripples in the pool that can
add or cancel depending on how they fit
together
now I'm I want to describe a rather
simple sounding rhyme and then we'll get
later to a more subtle run so we're
going to replace a point particle and
this is trying to be point particle of
course I had to give it some size so
that you can see it but think of it as a
a particle like an electron that is so
small we might as well think of it as a
point but now we're going to replace the
point particle with a vibrating string
so I've drawn an example of a loop of
string and if you let it free it'll
vibrate or oscillate in time so I call
it a vibrating string it won't just sit
there with this funny shape I've given
the curvature of the string will cause
it to expand or contract in different
directions and it will vibrate so I'll
draw a picture in space-time so we again
think of time as running vertically in
space as running horizontally and what
I've drawn is this trajectory of a point
particle so at any given time the
particles somewhere in space later on at
this time it's over here and that curve
physicists call it the world line of the
particle but that curve is a curve in
space-time that describes the motion of
the particle well here's the analogous
picture for a string again at any given
time we have a loop of string later on
the loop is here and still later it's
here and as time unfolds a string sweeps
out a two-dimensional surface in
space-time which we call the string
world sheet now in both pictures I drew
a smooth classical orbit because it's
too hard to draw anything else
especially in the case of this
but we're supposed to imagine a random
quantum four directory so I do a
classical picture but you should imagine
wild Wiggles here and also wild Wiggles
here because according to draw
confinement the quantum particle or a
string samples all possible orbits or
trajectories so what we're really
looking at here is a quantum random one
dimensional geometry in space-time or
quantum random two-dimensional geometry
so in the particle case of random
trajectory is a one-dimensional geometry
in space-time but a random one in the
string case it's a random
two-dimensional geometry I should warn
you I'm using the word random very
loosely it's random in a quantum
mechanical sense where cancellations are
possible because the randomness involves
wave amplitudes that have to be added up
before you try to measure them a
classical picture of what randomness
means doesn't really do justice to it
and there's also not time today to try
to straighten out that point but
therefore loosely just say that the
particle case has a random 1 dimensional
geometry and the string case has a
random 2 dimensional geometry where I'm
warning you that there's more to the
word random than I've been able that I
will be able to explain but you can
you'll do fine for the rest of the talk
just thinking of a random 1 or 2
dimensional geometry well one question
is why does this naive sounding idea of
replacing a point particle by a string
lead to something deep well I'm going to
give two answers we get one answer if we
think of a violin string so by a violin
string from my purposes I just mean a
string tied down at the two ends and it
can vibrate of course and here's the
simplest way can vibrate what's called
the fundamental harmonic part of I
brains violin string can vibrate in
multiple ways it could vibrate with this
shape or instead of just going up one
sit here it goes up and then down and
although I haven't drawn them a violin
string could vibrate with more of a
like that now if you only have this form
of vibration you'll get the fundamental
tone this one will be an octave higher
and so on the many ways that a string
can vibrate are responsible for the
richness of music if you want to hear
the fundamental tone you can get a good
approximation to it with a tuning of
work but the tuning fork sounds very
ugly to the human ear so we well we use
violins and other instruments like
flutes and so on we don't have symphony
orchestras made out of tuning forks
because people don't like the results so
to the human ear the beauty of music
comes from the interplay of the
different harmonics the different shapes
that the string can vibrate or analogous
statements for other instruments ok
that's the answer for stringed
instruments but there's an analog for
all the other instruments in the
orchestra well likewise the strings I'm
talking to you about can vibrate in many
ways but rather than a basic tone and
it's higher overtones for this kind of
string the different forms of vibration
correspond to different elementary
particles so if string theory is correct
the unity of the elementary particles
arises because the different automotive
particles are different forms of
vibration of one basic string so if
string theory is correct all the
elementary particles the ones you know
about and the ones you don't know about
if you're not physicists our different
states of vibration of the same string
so the electron the muon the up quark
the photon the neutrino and so on are
different forms of vibration of the
string so one answer to the question of
why this leads to something deep is that
because a string can unify it can
vibrate in many different ways it forces
us to unify the elementary particles and
their forces but there's another answer
that we can see if we rethink fineman's
elementary processes so remember this
was the basic picture in spacetime for
the simplest elementary process where
one particle breaks into two time was
running vertically in space horizontally
though haven't
repeated that here and here's the analog
of that process in string theory
so one string came in in the past and it
broke into two and roughly speaking this
picture does the same thing this one did
if this describes a PI well a particle
going to two other particles and if the
particles are really strings then this
still describes a particle going to two
other particles but there are some
important differences between the two
pictures in the string theory case
something happens but you can't say when
and where it happens so in the particle
case this was the definite space-time
event at which something happens but in
the string case any small piece of the
picture looks like any other small piece
I've sometimes been asked the following
question in the string case was there
not a last time at which there was one
string instead of two and there was in
any given coordinate system but Einstein
taught us and that a surface of constant
time isn't the same for all observers so
although I might regard this as a
surface of constant time and say
something happens here somebody else
would have a different surface of
constant time and would identify
different moments were one string broke
into two the important thing here is
that any small piece of this picture
looks like any other but here there was
a definite moment that's different from
the others so this is the beginning of
the fact it's the first sign of the fact
that familiar concepts of space and time
become murky and string theory somewhat
like the way classical mechanics sizing
like quantum mechanics made a lot of the
notions of classical Newtonian physics
become a little bit murky so in the
passage to quantum mechanics there was
an uncertainty principle that says that
you can't know exactly you can't have
all the information you'd have
constantly where you know where a
particle is and how it's moving at the
same time
in the case of string theory you can't
pin down space and time in the familiar
way so in the particle case there's a
definite space-time event the string
case still describes particle
interactions but without a definite
space-time event and while that is
probably a rather naive interpretation
of this picture it turns out supported
by many interesting calculations done by
now over a period of decades that this
is a first hint of something very basic
that the space-time concepts of physics
as we know it today are modified in
string theory going from the point
particle to the string gives it an
arrant fuzziness to space-time in a way
that's a little bit like how quantum
mechanics gives it an arrant fuzziness
to the orbit of a particle so I've
explained a possible rhyme string theory
repeats the established structure of
physics but with particles replaced by
strings and one-dimensional particle
trajectories in space-time replaced by
two-dimensional ones the particle
trajectories are world lines in the
language of physicists and the string
trajectories are world sheets but this
rhyme is not the deeper rhyme that I had
in mind with the title of this talk the
D prime concerns the other great
revolution in 20th century physics whose
centennial we celebrate this year
this is Einstein's theory of gravity
which he called general relativity
Newton had viewed space-time as simply
an arena in which events unfold Einstein
taught us that actually a big part of
the story is how space-time unfolds so
Newton had written equations that
describe where the particle will be
later on if you know where it is and how
it's moving at the initial time Einstein
did the same thing for space-time the
Einstein equations tell you what
space-time will look like later on if
you know what it looks like and how it's
changing at an initial time
the only trouble is that Einstein's
equations are describing
four-dimensional geometries and I
couldn't think of any reasonable way to
draw four-dimensional geometries for you
to explain in another way the difference
between Newton and Einstein Newton said
that the planets go around the Sun
because there's a gravitational force
pulling the planets to the Sun so
according to Newton there's a force from
the planet toward the Sun that causes
the planet to keep bending in the
direction of the Sun although by solving
his equations Newton discovered that the
particles that the planet never gets
there is always bending toward the right
and that means in the direction of the
Sun but it's got enough energy so that
it actually stays in the orbit I've
drawn Einsteins picture of the same
description of the same story is
different
Einstein said that the Sun curves the
space-time around it and the planets are
simply going on the straightest path
that there is in a curved space-time so
it's very important that what is phase
and what is curved here is space-time
and not just space so Einstein told us
that we have to include time along with
space on an equal footing and if you try
to do this
assuming that space is curved in that
space-time it really doesn't work
supposedly the 19th century
mathematician Bernhard Riemann who
invented the mathematical tools for
describing curved spaces had the idea
that gravity resulted from curvature but
he assumed it was curvature of space and
then it does it doesn't work Einstein
before he developed his theory of
gravity had learned to treat space and
time together in his earlier theory the
special theory of relativity and then so
when he tried to interpret this picture
instead of curved in terms of curvature
it was the space-time that was curved
with time playing a very essential role
and then in that context he was able to
show that the planet is simply moving on
the closest thing there is to a straight
path in a curved space-time
so it works beautifully and it leads to
the expanding universe black holes
gravitational lenses and all the rest
well I should say even farther back it
leads to very very nice success in
describing details of motion in the
solar system but also to these more
exotic things so for instance this is a
picture from the from the Hubble Space
Telescope and the arcs here come from
general relativity at work there are
images of very distant galaxies that
have been distorted gravitationally by
the gravitational fields of you're more
closer galaxies so you can I mean in
this type of picture of very distant
galaxies that are very massive New York
galaxies with much more distant galaxies
nearby in the sky the curvature of
space-time produces obvious effects of
greatly distorting the images of the
distant galaxies so Einstein's theory
works beautifully both in the solar
system and plenty of things that are
more exotic but from a modern point of
view there's a problem
well I'm Stein discovered his theory a
century ago this year as the Centennial
quantum mechanics was also discovered
roughly a century ago and this means
that we have to treat general relativity
quantum mechanically just as quantum
mechanics means that the deterministic
classical orbit of a particle has to be
replaced by random quantum orbit so was
the same true for the geometry of
space-time so what it means to treat
general relativity quantum mechanically
is that instead of the classical
space-time that Einstein envisaged where
if you know what it is at the initial
moment you solve his equations and learn
what happens later the quantum picture
would somehow have to replace Einstein's
classical geometry with the random
quantum geometry but we don't really
understand how to do random quantum
geometry in four dimensions
so remember 4 is the right dimension
because I'm signing cleated time so
space-time has the three obvious
dimensions of space
Einstein included also time in the
picture so it's a four-dimensional
space-time and with our familiar
physical and mathematical ideas and
techniques were not able to describe
four-dimensional random quantum geometry
so as I said already here you have to
bear in mind that forth the right number
because Einstein taught us to include
time but four-dimensional random quantum
geometry does not work on any
conventional lines because the nonlinear
mathematics that Einstein used in his
theory clashes with the requirements of
quantum theory so ok this is a conundrum
in physics so the two best theories of
the age are quantum theory and general
relativity and there has to be some way
to make them work together because for
example so we apply general relativity
to stars but the stars are all
ultimately made out of atoms and
subatomic particles we know that quantum
mechanics works for the subatomic
particles it doesn't make sense to have
one theory for the individual atoms
making up a star in a completely
different theory for the star there has
to be some way of combining the two
theories to make them work together
brought along conventional lines that
doesn't work well although we don't
really understand 4 dimensional random
geometry we found good use for 1 & 2
dimensional random geometry as I've
explained so the random ones in
dimensional geometry is an alternative
way to talk about our standard quantum
theories the theories developed
throughout the 20th century and the
random 2 dimensional quantum geometry is
the framework for possibly unifying
particles and forces in the context of
string theory so actually this is what
I've just had the 1 dimensional random
geometry is another way to describe
well-established physics and that's one
of nature's rhymes so
quantum gravity whatever it is would
involve four dimensional random geometry
and we don't understand it but other
areas of physics that we really do
understand can be described in terms of
one dimensional random geometry so this
is an example of nature repeating
herself with similar structures in
different places the one dimensional
random geometry that draw confine menus
to describe a quantum particle or the
four dimensional random geometry that
would hopefully reconcile Einstein's
theory with quantum mechanics but
there's a much deeper rhyme if string
theory is correct then first of all
random two dimensional quantum geometry
is key to unifying the forces the one
dimensional random geometry lets us
describe our quantum theories of today
but the two dimensional case
forces us to unify the particles and
forces because of the many different
ways that a string can vibrate but
there's something more to this which is
the deepest rhyme I have to offer you
today it turns out that one of the
states of a vibrating string so remember
for violin string this is the basic way
can vibrate and this is the second and
there are many many more likewise the
strings used in my kind of string theory
can vibrate in many different ways but
one of the states of the vibrating
string turns out to be a graviton a
basic quantum unit of the gravitational
field analogous to the photon which is a
basic quantum unit of light to say this
differently when we unify the elementary
particles and their forces using string
theory we get general relativity for
free as part of the bargain so if string
theory is correct it basically means
that two dimensional random quantum
geometry on the string worldsheet which
we know how to do although it stretches
our understanding we know how to do this
but it's relatively close to the
frontier of what we know how to do it's
the key to a new kind of
four-dimensional random quantum geometry
which we need but otherwise do not know
how to
and that's the deepest rhyme or
potential run that I have to offer you
today thank you
[Applause]